[Music]
historically movies and TV shows have
had a problem showing what coding and
hacking is actually like I think you
know what I'm talking about I'm trying
it's moving too fast many filmmakers
used to not bother making their scenes
accurate they went with their own idea
of hacking that looks exciting and feels
intense they were probably afraid that
if they went realistically they'd end up
with something like this so I go through
these thousands of lines of code and it
doesn't really matter so with a few
exceptions hacking in the 90s and 2000's
is either highly exaggerated or
incomprehensible and honestly I don't
blame the filmmakers for making this
choice watching someone sit at a
computer is boring and the vast majority
of movie goers didn't have a clue how
hacking works most of them probably
didn't care how it worked anyway but in
the last 10 years or so there's been a
big shift in how movies and TV portray
hacking maybe it's because the public
better understands how technology works
or maybe it's because people want more
realistic storytelling whatever it is
modern shows like mr. robot now have
extremely accurate hacking scenes and
even comedies like Silicon Valley put
some effort in fact checking the
technology they're making fun of but
even with all this new technical
accuracy there's still a bit of
deception going on filmmakers still make
hacking out to always be this incredibly
complicated process that requires a
technical genius you made it really hard
for anyone to see it but I saw it but in
reality a lot of the hacking you see on
the big screen is surprisingly easy
sometimes it's so simple you don't even
need experience to understand it all you
need is an internet connection and the
basic understanding of a few
vulnerabilities to prove my point let's
analyze the sequence from the social
network and see if you can do some
hacking yourself let the hacking begin
in this scene Mark Zuckerberg hacks into
websites on the Harvard Network and
steals pictures of female students for
his Facemash app not only is this seem
realistic but it's hacking that Marcus
Zuckerberg actually did in 2003 he
documented his techniques in an online
journal and some of the dialogue in the
movie is taken word-for-word from it
they keep everything open and allow
indexes and their Apache configuration
so little W get magic is all that's
necessary to download the entire
Kirkland Facebook kid stuff based on how
he delivers this line and how quickly
the moment flies by the average
moviegoer might think that this hacking
is only kid stuff for a genius like Mark
Zuckerberg even screenwriter Aaron
Sorkin felt this way her scenes in the
social network honestly I don't
understand when he's telling us how he's
hacking into things that's acquired
knowledge its phonetic knowledge but
this is probably the easiest hacking out
there that I promise you can do and I'll
prove it to you go to jack nugent io
/youtube mash in your favorite browser
it's a website built like Mark
Zuckerberg Facemash site except instead
of comparing girls at Harvard you can
judge all of now you see its past videos
go to the logo in the top left corner
and view the image every browser lets
you do this but the option just has a
slightly different name once you're at
the page with the image you just need to
remove the name with the image from the
URL and to get a list of all the
thumbnails from every now you see it
video and there you have it you're a
hacker like Mark Zuckerberg that's all
that he did it's true that he was clever
enough to check if this website had this
configuration and he also knew about W
get a package that lets you download all
the images on a webpage but this really
is kid stuff you don't need to be a
hacking expert to check if an images
location is in a website's public
directory if you tried this technique on
other websites it's probably not gonna
work because most websites have
tightened their security since 2003 even
this website is just faking it as of
this video's publish date Apache org
slash icons still indexes images the
exact same way that Zuckerberg exploited
if you want to see Apache indexing in
the wild excellent moving right along
later in the scene a mark needs to
quickly get a large stash of photos for
Facemash so he writes some code to do at
a time and there's no way I'm gonna go
500 pages to download pics one at a time
so it's definitely necessary to break
out Emacs and modify that Perl script
he's solving a simple problem it would
take too long to man you
we go through every page and download
the thumbnails instead he writes a few
lines of code that repeat the process we
just went through for every page on the
site not so complicated if you think
about it if you wanted to do this on the
jack cucchiaio slash YouTube mash site
the random video button gives you a
random thumbnail you could go through
all the URLs for each video and do the
same thing he did I'm doing it with
slightly different code but it's still
the same idea and now that you've got
all the images it's time to make
Facemash I need the word algorithm is
usually abused in movies to make
something instantly sounds epic all I
did was come up with my own kick-ass
algorithm to sneak in but an algorithm
is simply a step by step solution to any
problem it's an equation it's code or
it's even a recipe for making food the
algorithm for Facemash is copying what
chess players use to calculate their
ratings let's say the matrix a different
perspective has a rating of 1600 and y
jumpscares Suk has a rating of 1200 the
score just tells us the likelihood that
a video will win in any given matchup
the higher of videos eloah the more
likely it is to win because the matrix
video has a higher rating it's expected
to win 90% of the time and the
jumpscares video is expected to win 10%
of the time depending on who wins
another algorithm adjusts each video
score if a video wins that isn't
expected to win the algorithm adjusted
score more drastically because the
videos current score is apparently too
low
these videos starts with a rating of
1400 and the algorithm takes it from
there these equations are the exact same
way chess players get their Ehlo scores
and it's the same way Mark Zuckerberg
ranked women on their attractiveness and
now I'm using the same algorithm to find
out what you really think of now you see
at videos the social network is an
example of the current trend to make
hacking and movies and TV more accurate
but at first glance the movie still
portrays hacking as incredibly
complicated it only feels that way
because they make the dialogue really
fast and throw in software jargon like
Apache double you get and Emacs and then
all of a sudden it feels like you have
to be a genius to understand it but you
can do that with anything related to
technology I can do the same thing with
my YouTube mash webs
spin up a static site easy I'll just
create an s3 bucket underneath the CDN
surface with SSL encryption then all I
have to do is generate pages and Gatsby
for Lightspeed performance and automate
deployment with a collab CI algorithm
kids stuff
all that is just a fancy way of saying I
made a website of course not all hacking
is as easy as what they did in the
social network but filmmakers don't seem
to differentiate the simple from the
difficult so the next time you see an
insane hacking scene that makes no sense
to you don't forget that you can still
hack like Mark Zuckerberg hacking in
movies and TV has become more realistic
at least partially due to an increase in
computer literacy the average person
knows more about computers than ever
before and our entertainment reflects
that it's never been easier to learn how
to build a website or exploit the faults
in one you can learn how to make
websites using YouTube Stack Overflow or
there's a great tutorial by Christopher
Todd called understanding web
development
it's an incredibly well explained to
introduction to the basics of making
your own website from scratch if you
want to check out this video you can
view it on Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community that can help
you learn and grow even with a busy
schedule classes cover every topic from
film production to coding so if you're
interested in diving deeper into what I
discuss today it's the perfect resource
to get started so now that you know how
to hack like Mark Zuckerberg you can
learn how to code like him too but don't
worry you don't have to afford a Harvard
education to get there an annual
subscription is less than $10 a month
and the first 500 of my subscribers that
click the link in the description will
get a two month free trial of Premium
Membership so you can explore your
creativity plus it helps us out too
thank you guys so much for watching and
getting this far in the video I thought
up the idea for this video over the
summer but I put it on the back burner
because I was worried it didn't really
fit the style of the channel I was able
to make the video I wanted to make
because you guys were there supporting
the channel the whole time we wanted to
make an interesting weird video and if
you guys also think it was interesting
and you want to see more videos like
this then support us on patreon there
you can get early access to videos shout
outs in the credits and to
behind-the-scenes look at our script
process so support us on patreon or let
me know on Twitter or YouTube if you
like this kind of video and hopefully we
can make more of them thanks for
watching